the question that I want to ask you
ladies next though is what's more
important to you the the guy's past or
the guy's future with you future future
future so you're not so concerned with
what he's done in the past if he's able
to Pro you know provide preside he's a
strong masculine guy he's competent he's
got a good Network he's influential like
he takes off all the lady boxes right
handsome guy you know he's in shape
potentially lethal you know knows how to
fight um so it doesn't matter if he
got a you know bizarre past because
you're more concerned with his future
yeah see that's one of the differences
that men and women have is that I think
men are more particular about a woman's
past right like we'll like we'll look at
her her past choices what's her
relationship like with her father did
she follow his boundaries when he set
them did she break the boundaries um did
she share her body with a lot of men did
she preserve her value and her beauty
rather than share her herself so I think
you know for men it's a lot different
and I can see those differences you know
between men and women like I understand
the importance of a guy being able to be
there for women in the future because
she really doesn't care about the past
it's like whatever you know it's like I
think most women when you ask them do
you really care if the guy's been with a
whole bunch of girls they're just like
not really if he ticks off all the boxes
well I think what's interesting rich is
like it's this main character syndrome
it's this because we had Omen on last
week we had J on last week and she was
very keen
on what guys were doing in the past and
oh you took your ex to the males but you
didn't take me or you celebrated this
with her but you haven't done that with
me yeah so it's it's kind of this and
I've talked about my theory on this and
it's too nerdy to get in onto this show
but I'll talk about it maybe on another
one but it's ideally like women just
want to be they want to be that one they
want the the reason women love bad boys
so much is like it they have the same
sort of it's similar to what you see in
guy sort of the Savior schema Captain
Sabo if you will like I'm going to be
the one that's going to get her on the
right path and women want to also be
that that the women a lot of women have
this fantasy of like oh you know I was
the one that got them to settled down
you he might have went through 150 girls
and he was a Playboy but he put all that
away and he put his toys away his
childish things behind him when a real
woman stepped into his world and things
like that so I do think there's a part
of women that um care in the way that
they are his future and they're better
than anything he's had before I think
that sort of manifests itself
often but I'm curious what the ladies
think about that for me I have to say
that I'm more of
a like a country boy kind of girl those
are the kind kind of men that I like
manly strong work hard um if I know that
he's been a ladies man that is a turn
off for me it is and I I just I can't go
there because I've been hurt now I'm 49
I'm single obviously I've made some poor
choices in my life but I'm not the kind
of girl that's on the dating sites I
don't do that I don't go to bars I don't
go out and party so when I do meet
somebody I'm literally like oh I'm all
in and I choose wrong every single time
I was with the same man for 14 years he
was wonderful back in the day and then
he turned out to be a gambler and a
crack addict and then I left him and
rebound it with my daughter's father he
turned out to be an abusive man I had to
leave then I married someone else and he
ended up being a mama's boy left home
and wanted to be with his mama but I
could never date a man who's been a
ladies man because I know I could never
be enough he will step out that's in my
head is that is that wrong if a man
steps out on
you let me just rephrase that for a
second yeah if a man is in love with you
lives with you takes care of you
protects
you does everything that a man does but
from time to time he steps out not to
embarrass you I would want to know about
it pardon me I wouldn't want to know
about it a lot of women seem to want to
know about it they always ask questions
which I always find interesting cu the
truth is they don't really want to know
about what you're saying I do I do would
you just look the other way if you know
if he did it like he didn't do it to
hurt you like he didn't take this girl
to a restaurant that he takes you to
often he doesn't you know take her on
vacations it's like step out back in and
he's with you it's only sex it's only
sex uh I think it could still be a
liability why way um because I mean what
if they can fall in love up pregnant or
something I mean that's that's that can
be a liability yeah but he doesn't bring
he doesn't bring home a disease he
doesn't bring home a baby it's just he
steps out it's just sex just like Anna
just said
right what about you Anna what's your
take on that if the guy steps out and
just has sex I don't want to know you
just don't want to know about it you
don't want it rubbed in your face yeah
yeah yeah but you'd look the other way
if there was hints of it if everything
else is good um well I would ask why he
doing it because there's something
missing is there something missing I was
told this story by a a man friend of
mine here locally he actually did um
some work for me and uh he told me this
story how because he wanted to get with
me and I was not interested whatsoever
and uh anyway he told me this story
about this woman that he was having this
act of Affair within town and they would
only meet up during the day because
there was no suspect during the day so
they would like rent a hotel room and
they would meet up and she greeted him
at the door with a trench coat and naked
and whatever and I said oh you want me
to be trench coat lady anyway and I said
well from what I see on your Facebook
and everything like you're very happy
with your wife you do you want to leave
your wife he said no I'm very happy I
love my wife and I said do you still
have sex with your wife he said yes all
the time and I said well why would you
want to do that he said because it's
different well you got your answer it's
just different it's just variety right
yeah see that's what again you know back
to the point of I'm able to see from my
lens and from the female lens and the
female lens is you know I keep hearing
you know the same thing over and over
I'm not enough like um I don't want to
be that gal like I don't want to feel
like I'm not enough you know for the guy
and it's like it's not that these guys
and you got the answer from this guy
like right away it's not that you're not
enough it's just that he's he's looking
for some
variety right I think that any guy given
the
choice would definitely do it and I
think that throughout history you know
men have always behaved that way whereas
women I think it was Ellen that made
that point earlier it's like you know
what if he falls in love well what if he
doesn't fall in love what if it's just
sex and I think that you know for women
it's like they know that when they have
sex with a guy love is usually something
that is has either happened or is going
to happen in a reasonable period of time
right because women fall in love with
guys after sex you know several times
they like they it may not be love but it
but the affinity and the connection
strengthens and and grows whereas for
guy like I know guys that are killers
right athletes politicians entrepreneurs
that have done tons of stuff for their
life they've got you know a bunch of
kids with their wife they have to travel
you know they've uh they're super
successful they're high value guys and
women throw themselves at them right and
you know they'll step out from time to
time and the wife just looks the other
way because she knows that he's taking
care of everything it's the dynamic
right so like just say I I've been with
a man for 15 years and he built up his
uh wealth and he's famous and he's you
know very highly sought after there's
women throwing themselves at him if he's
providing for me and he's I mean I know
I can't stop it of course I'm going to
want that lifestyle and I'll probably
likely accept it
but if the guy is broke and he's
treating me like crap and he's running
around with every little hoe that's
going on no I'm not going to accept that
so it really depends on the dynamic and
what the Spectrum he's on I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clip's from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other have an amazing day peace out